Bonsoir Dans ce nouveau cette huile
société nous allons nous intéresser au
rythme scolaire une application décritée
par certains élus qui s'est mis en place
en deux phases dans les Yvelines neuf
communes sur 260 était déjà passé au
nouveau rythme scolaire en septembre
2013 donc trappes et puis les autres
villes ont un adopté elles en septembre
2014 alors deux mois après donc
septembre 2014 les vacances de la
Toussaint sont passées nous avons voulu
savoir comment cela s'organisait dans
les communes comment se mettaient en
place et nouveaux rythmes scolaires
combien surtout cela avait coûté et
quelle modification pouvait être
apportées dans l'organisation de ces
tempérisé éducatifs alors pour en parler
en plateau avec nous je ne Marie bonsoir
vous êtes mère adjointe à l'éducation à
Trappes trap qui je rappelle avait opté
pour les nouveaux rythmes scolaires dès
septembre 2013 donc du coup votre
éclairage sera forcément très
intéressant Jean-Michel fourgousse
bonsoir vous êtes maire d'Élancourt et
vous avez été l'un des premiers élus à
dénoncer cette réforme donc nous direz
comment ça se passe sur votre commune
Suzanne blanc bonsoir vous êtes mère
on va voir c'est plus tard le matin est
terminé à 16h30 cette année retour à
8h30 11h30
13h40 donc 13h15 et puis ensuite la fin
de l'enseignement à 15h30 voilà qui a eu
cette modification d'une heure vous avez
l'après-midi sur la demande des parents
sur la demande de la majorité du groupe
de travail
entre 2013 et 2014 sur le sujet
avec la mise en place effectivement d'un
comité technique paritaire d'un comité
de pilotage qui réunissait le monde de
l'éducation nationale les fédérations de
parents d'élèves ou les indépendants et
puis bien évidemment le personnel
municipal notre DGS un chef de projet
qui a conduit tout ça voilà et on a
essayé d'être fin prêt pour pour la
rentrée de septembre 2014
donc on a divisé on a 28 écoles en tout
on a fait deux groupes deux fois 14 2 x
14 écoles par secteur avec
soit le lundi et le jeudi avec des
organisations de temps d'activités
éducatives soit le mardi et le vendredi
vous aussi certaines écoles finissent à
15h c'est ça et puis deux fois par
semaine une fois par semaine donc le
temps l'été
éducatives
scolaire
ça dure ça dure donc une heure ça dure
une grosso modo une heure puisque bon le
temps de la mise en place puis du départ
de nouveau des enfants donc
comment ça se passait en cours est-ce
que c'est aussi une heure
donc
ça c'est 15 minutes plus 30 minutes bon
ça désorganise bien sûr beaucoup
la vie des enseignants la vie des
enfants qui sont beaucoup plus fatigué
d'abord que que or la réforme disait
qu'il serait moins fatigué
contrairement aux autres communes ça se
termine c'est ce terme oui à 16h oui et
donc on a une demi-heure plus 15 minutes
par la pose Mayenne donc
on sent bien que les profs bien sûr sont
très désorganisés et surtout la question
des profs et ça c'est très important
c'est même leur syndicat qui dit ça
c'est ils disent quel est le lien entre
la réussite scolaire alors les rythmes
scolaires
on veut bien dépenser plus on veut bien
prendre des risques mais est-ce qu'il y
a un lien on en parlera ou pas
intéressant évidemment avec le recul de
trap et vous en tout cas c'est 16h j'en
ai comment ça se passe à la verrière à
quelle heure les les petits sortent de
l'école chez vous
tous les jours il sortait auparavant à
16h donc un changement considérable
les élémentaires eux peuvent sortir
aussi à cette heure-ci ou sinon à 15h15
quand on a les notes parce que nous on a
décidé de deux fois oui alors
comme ça on a décidé de faire deux fois
une heure trente pour les élémentaires
de manière à avoir des activités
éducatives intéressantes et riche et
pour les maternelles on a décidé de les
étaler en demi-heure tous les jours sur
la semaine donc plus une demi-heure et
puis 1h30 pour les pour les primaires à
Saint-Cyr-l'École comment ça se passe
donc c'est la fin d'école à 15h40 on a
une dizaine d'écoles on a des écoles
donc on a scindé la ville en deux et la
moitié à
l'étape le lundi et le mardi et l'autre
moitié le jeudi et le vendredi l'école
c'est ami à 15h40 on a une gare de est
gratuite entre 15h40 et 16 heures qui
permet en fait de dispatcher les enfants
en fonction des activités
et ensuite ils ont une heure de tape
alors le lundi et le mardi ou le jeudi
et le vendredi et donc ils finissent
ensuite à 17h donc on voit que ça
s'organise à peu près tous la même
manière avec session des lancers
alors c'était la grande question
beaucoup de mer disait impossible de
recruter des animateurs est-ce que vous
avez votre volant d'animateur chacun
dans vos communes
que oui puisque vous non
il manque une vingtaine de personnes
entre 15h30 et 16h30 parce qu'il y a un
volume d'enfant qui reste ce volume est
très important puisque c'est l'étude et
qu'elle est gratuite et que cette étude
était réclamée par les parents donc il
manque une vingtaine de personnes encore
voilà le fait que vous ayez commencé
à 412 personnes quand même voilà
vous aviez organiser vous un
ce qui nous a permis ce jour-là de
pouvoir effectivement avoir 19 personnes
d'ores et déjà
7 ans ont été recrutés par la suite donc
26 en tout recruter entre le mois de
juin et la rentrée
qui s'ajoute bien sûr à tous les
intervenants enfin à tous les animateurs
plus les intervenants que nous avions et
que nous avons
et au-delà de ça au delà de ça on va
essayer on a on est en train de
réfléchir parce qu'effectivement il y a
un problème sur l'organisation de du
laps de temps entre le moment où les les
temps d'activité périticatives se
terminent et puis
le fait que des enfants partent entre
chez eux d'autres restent au
périscolaire donc là voilà on a il
faudrait on va essayer de trouver une
solution pour que ça se passe au mieux
et avoir un petit peu plus de monde
voilà à cette à ce moment à ce moment
vous allez faire la guerre
pour rechercher les animateurs comment
ça se passe dans vos dans vos communes
alors aussi pour les animateurs est-ce
que vous avez peut-être
on a eu aussi des défections puisque au
début de l'année nous avons manqué
quelques-uns on arrive aujourd'hui à
recruter ce qui les personnes
nécessaires et on a 12 intervenants
supplémentaires donc en fait on est de
les recruter non c'est pas facile c'est
un peu compliqué mais on a trouvé auprès
des universités notamment université de
51 en Yvelines et auprès de Pôle emploi
et au niveau des qualifications vous
avez vous animateurs ont tous le BAFA
on a que 725 élèves nous un sur la
verrière c'est une petite commune on a
trois scolaires dont un établissement
régional on était amené à recruter 12
animateurs supplémentaires dont 8 en
emplois d'avenir et on a fait une
passerelle avec la Ligue de
l'enseignement pour préparer l'entrée de
ses futurs animateurs dans la commune et
pour les intégrer donc de ce point de
vue là ça c'est plutôt bien passé
maintenant je cacherai pas non plus
qu'on a quelques difficultés de temps en
temps avec un certain nombre d'entre eux
parce que ils sont jeunes et parce que
le début était parce qu'il manque un peu
et il y a un problème aussi de
fidélisation bien sûr parce que les les
communes aussi offrent des fois des
salaires un peu plus importants que ce
que nous on peut offrir et donc du coup
mais globalement c'est plutôt bien c'est
plutôt bien
côté animateurs
parce que
en fait une inégalité très forte entre
les communes et qui évident que
de ces jeunes enfants c'est important
alors c'est vrai qu'on s'en doute que ça
peut être sur le nombre effectivement de
recrutement à faire parce que d'un seul
coup est arrivé comme ça sur le marché
du travail une forte demande il est
arrivé aussi que ce cette réforme amène
des nouveaux métiers d'animateur pour
lequel les animateurs ne sont pas
préparés au jour d'aujourd'hui donc ça
fait beaucoup de choses à mener sur la
table précipitamment qui nous tombe
dessus comme ça nous collectivité locale
pour autant on arrive quand même à
recruter ce qui fait la difficulté c'est
que souvent on a besoin de beaucoup de
personnes sur le temps de 15h30 15h30
puisque chez nous c'est l'étude et que
une heure de travail c'est la vraie
précarité on peut pas demander à des
gens
vous avez des cours de piano vous avez
des cours de violon sans autre commune
vous avez de la pâte à modeler ou de la
valoriser
faut quand même je suis pas certain
quand même que c'était la finalité de
cette réforme je pense qu'il faut que
inégalité du service public la question
de l'équité c'est confondre les nappes
et puis les activités périscolaires
c'est un peu un peu différent sur les
nappes nous on a pris des professionnels
et il y a un certain nombre d'animateurs
bien sûr mais il y a des professionnels
d'un certain nombre de corps de métiers
du théâtre de la musique mais là c'est
un peu différent quand on parle
d'animateur c'est l'encadrement des
enfants après une partie des activités
d'étapes et menées par les animateurs
nous on leur a demandé de nous
proposer un projet éducatif ça veut dire
que on leur ils font pas une animation
classique qui se fait vraiment quelque
chose d'éducatif
il n'empêche que
recruter ces gens là c'est quand même
compliqué parce qu'il faut qu'ils aient
les compétences il faut qu'ils aient
l'envie il faut qu'ils construit quelque
chose et c'est pas si simple que ça je
suis un peu d'accord avec vous et c'est
à nouveau c'est un peu un nouveau métier
en fait ce qu'on a constaté quand on a
mis en place le comité technique et le
comité de pilotage c'est que pour
certains de nos animateurs ils
ressentait ça comme vraiment une
valorisation de leur métier et donc ils
étaient extrêmement heureux pour
beaucoup de ce qui était déjà en place
de pouvoir enfin peut-être montrer leur
spé leur spécificité ou leur spécialité
ce qui joue de la guitare c'est toujours
ou qui fait du théâtre ou voilà donc ça
c'est une chose pour ceux qui n'avaient
pas de de spécificité à proprement
parler il y a eu il y a eu des
formations et il y en aura encore au
delà de ça on a aussi on a aussi
interpellé nos toutes nos associations
sportives et culturelles bon ça c'est
plus mais ça se comprend que ce soit
plus difficile parce que on peut être
dans une association être très bon dans
ce qu'on fait être un excellente acteur
ou d'excellents musiciens mais pour
autant la pédagogie c'est autre chose
même si on n'est pas dans dans la
pédagogie
c'est que du coup les directeurs de
centres loisirs directeur et directrices
c'est un nouveau métier ils ont beaucoup
plus de responsabilités parce que avant
il fallait animer des groupes d'enfants
mais sans donner de cours sans apprendre
quoi que ce soit là on leur demande en
plus d'avoir de construire un projet
pédagogique et ça et ça c'est nouveau
pour eux et c'est et c'est valorisant et
ça veut dire que dans les années à venir
il va falloir les revaloriser aussi
peut-être
que je comprends malgré tout c'est que
du coup un peu dans toutes les communes
il y a des choses différentes qui se
font est-ce que autour de cette table
vous pensez quoi que c'était vraiment
aux communes à prendre en charge ce
temps péril éducatif ou alors il fallait
finalement que ce soit une enveloppe
d'état vous allez me dire à l'État n'a
plus d'argent est-ce que ça devrait pas
être une enveloppe d'État globalement
pour toutes les communes avec la
programmation
en 1995 et donc même avant quand
Philippe Seguin avait lancé l'idée voilà
mais ça c'était une vraie idée avec des
vrais choses choses à l'appui avec des
subventions énormes voilà
c'était extraordinaire parce que on
avait on avait été retenus comme commune
comme une pilote à Montigny et donc
c'est vrai qu'au niveau de la création
d'emploi sur l'ensemble de notre pays ça
aurait été un truc fabuleux bon ça fait
peur à tout le monde
ça fait peur parce que comme toujours
quand on change d'habitude et bien c'est
difficile mais là on est quand même
c'est pas on est quand même vous êtes
d'accord assez loin de ce que l'on est
loin parce que
c'est à dire que du coup ça nous est
tombé dessus nous tous voilà ça nous est
tombé dessus qu'il a fallu bon c'était
un décret c'était pas une loi certes
mais enfin on savait bien que à partir
du moment où le décret était sorti il
allait falloir l'appliquer donc voilà
donc on a tous travaillé même si parfois
on a on a pu douter mais on a donc tous
tous travaillé et c'est vrai que là on
est plus dans la même configuration que
ce qu'avait envisagé Philippe Segara on
est vraiment dans une configuration où
on doit effectivement faire face nous
même c'est-à-dire nous-mêmes
de le faire ou honnêtement
enfin qu'on est qu'on est à charge de se
parler du coup
voilà c'était c'était une façon de
parler non mais je veux dire qu'on soit
effectivement contrairement à ce qu'on
fait par rapport à l'éducation nationale
ou là l'éducation nationale est là et ça
c'est une chose mais au niveau des
communes puisque c'est du personnel du
coup qui dépend de nous la bien
évidemment il est normal qu'on y mette
notre mot voilà pour pas dire plein de
sel mais au-delà de ça c'est vrai que
l'État aurait pris en charge un certain
nombre de choses or comme vous allez
nous interroger sur le coup on sait tous
très bien à l'heure actuelle ce que va
donner l'état cette année peut-être un
petit peu l'année prochaine on en est
quand même pas sûr donc voilà c'est la
grande différence elle est là et on n'a
pas vraiment puisque on est tous un peu
bloqué dans nos dans notre pas gestion
financière mais en tout cas dans nos
dépenses quand même oui voilà faut le
dire
des emplois précaires parce que être
animateur d'une commune c'est l'emploi
précaire alors là non non non non non
non
c'est très difficile finalement
est-ce que c'est moi
que c'était plutôt de la compétence de
l'État c'est une demande de la réforme
des rythme scolaire c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui vous avez raison je me
suis dit c'est Philippe Seguin l'idée
était généreuse elle était bonne et
c'était plutôt à l'état de la mettre en
œuvre de manière équitable sur
l'ensemble du territoire
on va pas rentrer dans les détails de la
dépense publique mais enfin bref je
pense que j'en ai fait voilà
puisque philippe nous avait transmis son
projet donc on nous étions prêts à le
mettre en place sur la ville de Trappes
sauf qu'on a trouvé une situation
financière qui ne s'y prêtait pas qu'il
a fallu d'abord rétablir et qu'ensuite
est-ce qu'il aurait est-ce que là pour
cette nouvelle réformes il aurait fallu
que ce soit l'état qui prenne ça en
charge ou c'était le rôle des communes
je pense qu'il fallait que l'État laisse
le temps aux communes de s'approprier le
projet de façon différente de ce qui a
été fait et aussi anticipe le problème
de l'État que soit ce gouvernement là où
la précédente c'est l'anticipation
l'attente toujours comme ça dessus on
s'arrête toujours au milieu du guet ce
qui arrive ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
c'est la moitié de ce qu'a fait voulait
Philippe Seguin c'est mi-figue mi-résa
c'est voilà
c'est plus simple de définir un vrai
projet y compris d'État pourquoi pas
ils ont pas fait votre bureau disons
le problème de nos Hémis c'est les
résultats scolaires de leurs enfants ils
veulent ce qu'il y a de mieux
quand on regarde le classement
international pizza
c'est Shanghai qui est en tête j'y suis
allé à Shanghai pourquoi parce que je
suis un chercheur
et bien pourquoi ils ont eu mes
résultats j'aimerais savoir parce que le
nombre d'heures de cours est beaucoup
plus important d'heures de cours pas
d'animation de de belles prisonniers ou
de pâte à modeler ou de
cours de quoi donc c'est ça c'est ça et
c'est pour ça que nous on a demandé par
mail ils vont à ce moment-là les profs
parce qu'il y a un problème de la
pédagogie c'est très bien que les
animateurs sont pas formés c'est un
métier bon et bien les profs du Nord
c'est quoi ce truc c'est notre métier
que ça bon on sent bien qu'il y a un
problème là donc nous on a demandé ce
que les profs il y avait écouté on vous
paye en heure sup bon il y en a que 25%
dans tous ensemble ça marche pas donc
c'est ça fonctionne
qui a été défini il était dit que les
enfants en difficulté était pris en
charge par les enseignants parce que
c'est leur métier je vous rejoins
là-dessus c'est le métier la pédagogie
c'est le métier de l'éducation nationale
il prenait les enfants en difficulté ils
étaient pas obligé de rester dans ce
groupe comme ça toute l'année pouvait
progresser et aller rejoindre un groupe
qui était le groupe des moyens qui
celui-là est encadré par des bacs plus
plus on en a aussi et puis le groupe des
Autonomes il y a aussi des enfants
autonomes qui peuvent faire leurs devoir
tout seul ça va plus se mettre en place
parce qu'on n'a pas encore suffisamment
d'enseignants mais moi je désespère pas
vous savez c'est une année d'observation
si cette année sur train pour
l'éducation nationale et quand on voit
les résultats globaux de la réussite
éducative qui est en place depuis 1989 à
Trappes avant le Plan de Cohésion
Sociale de Jean-Louis Borloo depuis 1989
et que quand on à Charles à vouloir
absolument accompagner les enseignants
les parents les personnes là qui
travaillent auprès des enfants
aujourd'hui on a des résultats scolaires
et voici ça qui m'intéresse le résultat
j'aurais juste le côté
il nous reste 3 minutes pour finir je
voudrais qu'on parle quand même des
coups
attrape 1,6 millions d'euros là je parle
globalement après il y a les déductions
1,6 millions d'euros Montigny 1,2
millions la verrière
280 et 300000
j'ai pas dit le nombre d'élèves il y
avait plus il y a plus de 4000
presque 4000 à Montigny et l'emploi
600000 euros et je préfère
à la fin parce que pour l'instant c'est
que des projections et on va additionner
les petites rivière parce qu'il a fallu
être tous à peu près au même niveau
quel que soit
qu'on a regardé puisqu'ils ont démarré
avant tout le monde cela bon
400 euros par élève environ bon
expliquez-moi pourquoi le gouvernement
continue à dire que c'est 150 euros par
a commencé par Monsieur Hamon avouer et
avouer que c'est quand même un peu un
peu troublant parce que il s'agit quand
même des de nos finances dont on est
responsable nous dire les gens ont des
balances des chiffres comme ça moi j'ai
toujours un peu surpris bon voilà
les faiseurs ne sont pas les mêmes
parce que vous disiez d'abord
à la recentrer l'apprentissage dans les
fondamentaux parce que ça va être
beaucoup d'enfants qui sort de de CM2
qui savent difficilement lire écrire
compter et en plus elle revalorise pas
les profs aujourd'hui les professeurs
les prochains écoles sont dévalorisées
d'un point de vue financier sont pas
c'est un métier qui est pas reconnu et
cette réforme là ne fait rien dans ce
sens là donc
qui va passer payante
Suzanne bloc
c'est chez vous ça parce que à partir du
17 novembre effectivement l'heure va
devenir payante voilà parce que ça s'est
trouvé que on a eu une discussion
riche avec les parents d'élèves avec et
c'était dans le projet mais et en vérité
et on s'est retrouvé là pour quelque
chose qui concernait que les fratries
pour tous les enfants et là c'est pas
possible tout simplement voilà à partir
de 7 novembre à La Verrière mais
globalement en un mot cette réforme
c'est du plus
ou du moins ou en attente de voir
expérience à la réussite éducative c'est
un complément sur le territoire de
Trappes
je
suis très heureuse de voir tout le mal
que se donne ce qui interviennent auprès
des enfants et puis on va voir pardon et
qui seront récompensés
les résultats scolaires il faut changer
la pédagogie en France ou la rendre
beaucoup plus interactive beaucoup de
participer il faut changer le contenu
des programmes et surtout la formation
des profs qu'il faut renforcer les
rythmes scolaires c'est complètement
dépassé c'est pas la bonne question
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas en tout cas
du moyen je pense que c'est du plus il
faut que ça s'inscrive dans la durée et
puis on verra à mon avis dans cinq ans
vous reviendrait dans 5 ans
inefficace coûteuse et surtout elle le
prend pas en compte le rythme biologique
des enfants c'est à dire que la vraie
réforme qui aura été de réduire les
vacances scolaires et bien elle n'a pas
été faite parce que comme d'habitude le
gouvernement reculé
merci beaucoup d'être venu débattre
autour de cette question des rythmes
scolaires sur cette vie de société est
terminée merci de votre attention et
bonne soirée